oh brilliant
that's in mind please and also if you
want to speak
please indicate in the usual way
um chair uh martin has switched his um
his view to live so the stream is now
live chair
thank you thank you or good afternoon
everyone
and uh welcome to our auditing corporate
governance scrutiny committee
so we'll start with item one apologies
for absence please
i've received a policy from councillor
kerry chair
thank you any other apologies may i had
sarah sternberg monitoring officer chair
thank you we move to item two then
declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
interest and or other interest not
already on their register of interest in
any item on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
so presumably there's no declarations at
this moment um i had him three minutes
of the last meeting
approved as a correct record the minutes
of the meeting held on the 30th of
january 2020 they have been circulated
can we have a proposal that they are
drawing accurate record please
propose it
second by council shipment all in favor
thank you that is carried so we moved to
item four then reports of the external
auditors from bazaars so we're we have
with us this afternoon mr mike
norman so welcome mr dorman so
uh hand over to you just to use a
preliminary outline please
because yeah yeah good afternoon
everybody uh
there's two two papers from us the first
paper relates to the
uh audit strategy memorandum which uh is
one of the
three main communications we have with
the audit committee
and sets out the work that we we plan
for the year
uh this was originally due to be issued
uh but it was issued to its officers in
in january was due to be considered at
the
um i think the march meeting which
obviously was cancelled on in the
event of covid uh so given that it is a
formal communication that we need to
actually get to you we've had to shift
it to this agenda
now it does overlap a little well a lot
with uh
another item on the agenda which we'll
move on to in relation to the
completion completion work so i didn't
want to go into too much detail
because there is some overlap but what
it sets out is the
the significant risks that were
identified for the audit year
provides an update uh on on how we
we responded to those during the year um
and also gives a link through to one of
the appendices the
the ways in which the council has
considered uh the closed down issues
relating to covid
given that there's overlap between this
and the the next report which ties into
the the statement of
statement of accounts our audit
completion required i didn't want to say
too much more at this stage but i'm
happy to
thank any questions if there are any
thank you sirs
any questions
i think from my point of view mr norman
i think um having read the memorandum of
course it's the
the usual setting out of uh what we'd
expect to see of course appendix 2 and
the um
details about kovid are probably
the issues that we are more interested
in this moment in time
seeing as we are possibly facing wave 2
and what happens
next and the implications for this
council so we're
i think as we move into the uh the next
part of your report
there'll be things that you may get
questions on
we all are accepting of the memorandum
then we'll move to uh the audit
completion report
over to you please mr norman yeah so
the the purpose of the audit completion
report is to communicate to you as a
committee
uh the main findings from our uh our
audit work
and to give you an understanding of any
particular issues that we need to to
bring to your attention
this is what's going on this is uh so
you again i mean
i'll see the second item on the generous
view to formally consider the accounts
that have been audited
um and to give you some comfort or
assurance over the uh
the content of those but the actual
program i'm talking to i think was
issued as a supplementary
um agenda item
um and the the domain
i mean do we include an executive
summary within that
um page six uh
of the of the pack page three of our
report
gives a a paint picture of the the four
main areas of our responsibilities
and the first is relation to the
financial statements and it's to confirm
that
what we're proposing to do is you know
subject to completion of the
the small number of remaining items is
to give an unqualified opinion on the
financial statements that you've got in
front of you
second area relates to our
responsibilities remaining
relating to value for money and again we
anticipate giving an unqualified
money for money conclusion on on that
area uh the third area is a whole
government accounts
uh we we give confirmation to
the national audit office regarding the
uh
the return that the council itself needs
to send off and whether that's
consistent with the the accounts that
we've audited
we expect to be able to uh to issue a
clean opinion on that but
at this at this stage because national
audit office
haven't actually confirmed their
instructions uh we need to wait until
that's
that's done but that will follow the
issue of the opinion anyway
the fourth main area is relation to our
wider powers so we
have a responsibility to consider any uh
questions from electors any objections
and there are also some other areas in
which we've got the um audit powers and
can take action if need be
it's really to confirm on that finally
area we have received no
uh questions or objections from any
members of the public or electors
and there's no no reason why we need to
take any formal action
in that in that area um
on page four of our report page seven of
the
the pack we set out the uh the the kind
of position on the the order to the
stage
um and we're pleased to confirm that
we've covered four main areas there uh
plant property and equipment we just
need to tidy up some
some residue residual queries in
relation to that area
um and that that should be done within
the next week or so
um we've referred into you know and
therefore there's a um
within our orders opinion uh we are
proposing to give
an emphasis of matter relating to the
disclosed
material valuation uncertainty that's in
the council's accounts
i just wanted to confirm for the the
committee is that the
the material uncertainty that your
valuers have reported in their
valuation reports again ties back to
the covert situation as entirely
consistent with professional guidance
that they've been given by
royal institutes of childhood surveyors
and given that they've disclosed that
material uncertainty
you've quite rightly referred to that in
your disclosures to your financial
statements
uh and and what we're we need required
to do as part of our audit opinion
is just draw attention to that
disclosure in your financial statement
so it's um it's entirely consistent with
virtually all of the clients
um in the public sector in many sectors
this year
uh and again this isn't a qualification
but again we've um we
just need to draw attention to that uh
on the pension side
um there's one area of work where we
rely on assurances from the diversity of
pension fund audit
auditors that works still in progress
we expect that again to be available
within the next couple of weeks
um the delay in the pension fund
audit opinion again ties back to some
additional testing i understand they've
needed to do on the back of both the
training review
and as a consequence of the the covert
implications on valuations of assets
um there are no issues that we've been
made aware of as part of that but that
work
is subject to the final stages of their
review
in the detail of our report we've
referred
to a subsequent valuation report that
officers commissioned
relating to some changes in the
liabilities on the pension fund this
year what's called the mcleod case
um and so your officers commissioned a
supplementary report
to take into account those issues and
they required that they
have chosen to reflect the required
valuation in europe the updated
financial statements
so um again there's nothing nothing else
to to report on that matter
uh i mentioned the whole of government
accounts um
uh work which again we're waiting on
national auditor office instructions for
and already then went to the final
stages of the final stage review
um with a view to to issuing the opinion
uh the deadline nationally for ford's
opinion is the end of uh end of november
this year
within our report we've just set out the
changes to the timetable nationally
um and as i say at this stage we expect
to be able to complete that within the
next couple of weeks
only a while ahead of the the end of
november
deadline there are no other points in
the audit report that i need to
draw to your attention i'm taking it as
as read with
includes the information required to to
bring to your attention
say there are no unadjusted um
kind of um items above our reporting
threshold that we need to flag your
attention
no internal control deficiencies um
we flagged up clearly there were some
issues relating to
uh the impact of covid 19 on your
financial standing as there is on every
other
local council going forward and that
hasn't had an impact on
um both your own financial standing and
then the way in which
ways in which you're working but we're
not we're flagging them more for issues
to to consider to keep under a watching
grief for 2021 onwards
and we will revisit those areas as part
of future work
but they're the only points i wanted to
flag but clearly if there are any
questions from anybody
uh as part of the report that we've put
through
you to answer them
anything from our section 151 officer
no thank you chair thank you
obviously um i think as a council it
would be right for us to perhaps
talk about the pensions considerations
that you you touch upon
and i think in due course that's
something from
an audit committee that we may wish to
revisit and have an interim report about
progress on pensions you have flagged it
up and rightly so
as part of your um report to us and i
think as an audit committee something we
should keep an eye on
of course the covid situation for us is
uh as i've already said
the major consideration i think what
would be interesting for northeast
derbyshire to do
is a benchmarking exercise and how we
fit against councils of a similar nature
and where we we fit against them we are
hearing quite a few councils
experiencing financial difficulties some
talking about section 114 notices
or the possibility of um
looking at um how to rein in spending
without
issuing a section 114 notice so as near
as they possibly can but without doing
that
where does northeast derbyshire fit in
relation to those councils
and we we've not mentioned the b word
brexit
um and what brexit might mean um a no
deal brexit
i know it's referred to elsewhere in
reports but again i think
um it would be remiss of us not to
consider those and financial
implications
any com comments on that mr norman
yeah that the sorry interrupt the um
i mean both of those areas overlap uh
with the
the value for money consideration and
the separate report that we give on that
um this was the uh 2019-20s the final
year under the current
code of practice which is updated every
five years by the national audit office
now they've been very clear in their
guidance to us
uh for in carrying out the assessment
for this year that um
we need to look at 1920 and the impact
of
um well particularly covid and
perhaps in the more medium term brexit
is you know are there any any
illustrations of any sort of
fundamental failings in your your
arrangements
now to some extra to a great great
extent the implications from covert of
um
in unpredictable albeit as a council
you'd be expected to make sure that
you're able to withstand some
contingencies
and deal with um deal with situations in
that now
so given that there's that straight cuts
off that's what we've been able to
to issue an unqualified conclusion for
for 1920.
national office has been quite clear
that they expect the focus on
financial standing resilience and also
long-term well medium to long-term
implications from brexit
and uh kobit 19 to form part of the 2021
value for money assessment now we were
expecting some guidance around the
particular areas of focus on that
what we're expected to consider and
report on
um it develops uh during the summer but
clearly
uh along with a lot of other plans that
hasn't uh hasn't transpired
we will be we will be considering the
things you just mentioned as part of the
2021 work and reporting them
both in our risk assessment in the audit
strategy memorandum
and in the um and in the audit
completion report that we're bringing
along to
the end of at the end of the year
and clearly we are aware like yourselves
there's some councils in some areas that
are in quite significant difficulties at
the moment
i have whether section 151 officer is
having to
take some of the more extreme measures
required
as part of that to deal with not as a
matter of urgency
i think in our report we have given
acknowledge the steps that were taken
um in in after the the issue emerged
to to rebase the budget um
we seek to use uh to access as many
grants as possible etcetera and clearly
the
conference inc and compensation schemes
available to you at the moment
um we've commented on that acknowledge
that the council took the steps it
needed to do
and those steps have been effective
clearly there's still a lot of
uncertainty around that this point and
we will need to
revisit those themes and report back to
you at the end of the year
thank thank you councilman
yeah thanks chad um just going to your
benchmarking
idea martin does that can we make that a
recommendation from this committee that
that the council uh instigates that i
just
i think it's what you said i fully
support and i think
there's all these things coming down the
line and the more prepared we are the
better
i quite like the vote martin thing
because obviously we're hearing
all the other councils in a hot place
worse place than us but
uh the more we know the better prepared
we are i just wondered
do we need to make that a formal thing
or not which just asked the
section one five one officer to to see
if she's preempted me and
thinking about a benchmarking exercise
and then we'll move back to
your comments thank you chair yeah
absolutely
we're already doing quite a lot of
benchmarking some of it is an informal
basis um i meet with my fellow section
151 officers of cross derbyshire
every wednesday afternoon and we have
done since the 20th whatever it was of
march
because because of this very issue and
it's not just the budgets that are under
pressure it's the
it's the debt collection that's under
pressure as well which is going to
affect all of our collection funds so
there's lots of issues for us to
consider so i i wholly support it
we're also doing quite a lot of
benchmarking on income with um
an organization called pixel financial
management who do a national
benchmarking exercise
and they're pitching against like um
authorities so they'll put us into
family groups
so i've got a wealth of information i've
been more than happy to share with the
committee
thank you and we'll be more than happy
to see it so i think taking your
recommendation council barca i think
what we'll do is
um we will ask for this to be agended
for our next meeting
um so that what we will see is some
benchmark information
so if there's a wealth of it out there
we will be able to have a look at it
scrutinize it and um and discuss the
implications for northeast derbyshire
so we will include that on the next
agenda
any other comments or questions
if not can we move to recommendations to
paragraph six so we have six point one
and six point
two do we have a proposal please
i'll propose thank you council shipment
do you have six
six point three as well so that's
council armitage all in favor
thank you that's carried so um we're
going to authorize the
financial officer to sign the letter on
behalf of the council thank you mr
norman for coming along
and thank you for your input today thank
you
so we now move to item five reports of
the head of finance and resources and
section 151 officer
so a is statement of accounts please
you know what i'm going to say
thank you chair
okay this is the report that presents
the statements of accounts that mike's
just addressed in his audit completion
report so i'm not going to go through
the
the numbers but of course i'm happy to
take any questions with regards to the
statement of accounts
and that i can do they're attached
appendix one to the report
and that's what recommendations 6.1 and
6.2 of the report allude to
address sorry not alluded to i would
like to just touch on the
um assessment of going concern that we
built into this report
in some detail this year going concern
as a concept is something that the
councils
have always had in existence it's been
an operational existence and it's all
about making sure that we can continue
to operate for the foreseeable future
this it's an assumption that underpins
the accounts and to be honest it's
largely been just an accepted state of
affairs for local authorities
but with the advent of northampton a few
years ago and particularly because of
being
covered it's something that we're
wanting to give much more
we wanted to bring more to the forefront
i think for want and better words
so what i've tried to do in this report
is is built together an assessment
of the going concern status of the
council and
whilst this is retrospective looking at
20 1920 because it forms part of
2019-20s accounts
as mike said we've also got an eye on
looking forward to 2021
and we need to have the confidence that
the assessment for going concern
can continue into the future years
especially as we're about to set a
medium-term
financial plan for the next four years
so the remainder of the report from 1.6
through to 1.2
it does go on quite a lot i'm afraid
1.25
is addressing that particular assessment
and i looked at things like the current
council's current financial position the
projected financial position which is
what we do through the mtfp
the balance sheet the cash flow the
governance arrangements and
our regulatory and control environment
that we're expected to operate within
having done that piece of work i do feel
that i can offer some assurances
that we are operating as a going concern
we have been able to produce a balanced
budget or be
taking account of the effect of coved
and
although i know it is going to be a
challenge to us i'm expecting that we're
going to be able to produce a balanced
budget for next year as well
so they on that basis i'm happy to
recommend to the committee that we
have done the assessment for going
concern and that we are in a position to
be able to continue
with that position and i'm happy to take
questions chair
thank you are there any comments or
questions
[Music]
well i've got a couple as you would
expect
obviously kovid 19 and set out at 1.12
in the
covering report of course there's
greater concerns outlined and so on
but we also mention in the in the report
itself about key strategic risks
and there is reference to the emergency
plan enforced in march
um where are we now with the emergency
plan
and um how effective has it been
my understanding chair i'm not wholly
responsible for this as you'll be aware
but my understanding is that we do have
two recovery plans we have an internal
recovery plan and an external recovery
plan
they are monitored regularly through the
senior management team
um and i'd be happy for this committee
to get an update at the next meeting
which i'm sure you'd welcome
you must be a mind reader because i
think it's important that we do have
sight of the
recovery plans i think it's very good
for the cabinet to be having an overview
of it but i think this is a committee
that should see those internal and
external recovery plans and i think we
should scrutinize them
with regard to the financial
implications or otherwise
of their impact because
if there's a second wave and there's
local lockdowns and all these sorts of
things happening
um we need to know what's happening for
us next and i think the other thing in
terms of key strategic risks you you
have also mentioned
implementation of brexit in the report
so i've already alluded to that
previously in the last agenda item so i
think
um we shall watch with interest what
happens next nationally
because there will be implications for
us locally
and so we're i think that's important
that we should see and i'm also
interested to see impact of hs2
mentioned in the risk
um key strategic risks there
and the electrification of the midland
main line on the environment heritage
communities and businesses and i think
most of the
council will be interested to look at
the impact on
on our districts from hs2 um
whether it's positive or negative we
will have to determine
i think people know my personal views on
hs2
and i'm totally against it but i've set
my cards out
clearly on the table now but i think
it'd be important
where appropriate for us to have an
update on
key strategic risks from this narrative
report
an interim report at some point backed
for this committee to consider
or to you absolutely completely agree
chair it is a standing item normally on
the agenda
and risk management so i think it's this
agenda was is always quite busy because
of the final accounts and because of the
delays we've covered we've got quite a
heavy agenda so
i think that's absolutely right that we
should bring an update on strategic
risks and also the recovery plans which
should form part of that so
thank you i'm sure the committee will
agree with that and my own personal
little favorite on page 53 of the
narrative report
and we became the first district council
to sign up to the british sign language
bsl charter and then what
my understanding chair is that some
work's been done on that recently but i
have to be honest i'd
get back to you on that one because it's
not my area of speciality so
i will get back to you i'll be
interested to see what happens i think
it's all very well signing up to things
um and we can have a nice frame
something on the wall
and but i would like to see impact for
our residents who actually
are deaf and have hearing loss and we
know that in this district one in five
people have hearing loss
so um one of the financial implications
of this is
submitting money towards a scheme to
support people with disabilities
and then if nothing comes of it that's
not money well worth spending
and so i think we should be pursuing
that to make sure that it happens and is
implemented properly
happy to follow that up for you chair
thank you very much
any other councillor barker
yeah yeah thanks chet um i i do like
this narrative report
jane i mean it it's clear you know and
and it does sort of link into the to the
figures i just want to refer you to
page 60 or page 10 whichever one you
want to look at
um it's an it's the general fund and i'm
just looking at
there's a cumulative cumulative
shortfall of 4.5 million by 2324
uh that seems more than
than i'd go in my head i thought we were
2.7 million but
uh that seems a lot i just can you just
clarify that figure from me please
yes certainly can council vodka it is
2.7 million in the final year of the
mtfp but we
we add all of them together because if
we don't make what we need to next year
that rolls over and rolls over and rolls
over so
4.5 million is a worst case scenario
that makes sense but but that so we've
got to make the savings
prior to that and we've still got 2.7
million down
that's what that's exactly where we're
at yeah brilliant
okay and that's on top of the that's
before we
we've factored covered in then i think
absolutely yeah
yeah it's going to be a fun budget cycle
this time
best of luck jane thank you thank you
and council shipment
just on the um the signing of the
british sign language charter
um we had a a presentation that meet at
full council not
long ago about weren't the council
supposed to be introducing a system
online where deaf residents could go on
there and communicate
via some system um i'm just reading on
the website now and it says that
consultation with residents ended in
on the 9th of february 2020 what what's
actually happened with that there's
nothing back
on any committees i'm on about whether
we've implemented that i mean looking at
the website it doesn't look like it's
implemented at all
absolutely thank you for that question
carson shipment because
i believe it wasn't action by the
officer
um so i think the same question that
you've asked
is a question that i would be asking
again that we agreed as a council that
that would be a system we would
implement as a
an improved communication tool um the
people that cable as you will recall
went away with the idea that we were
going to sign up to that
communication system we were even
looking at possibly joining with balls
over district council for them to share
in that and for ricknald and um
nothing's materialized i did speak
recently with the chief executive of
rick nold
um and um we don't know where we are at
with it
so um i think the section 151 officer
has made some notes
so we can hopefully follow that up
so known that oh counselor armitage
thank you chair uh just on the
uh question of uh uh deafness
i uh well i'm not registered deaf but
i have uh impaired hearing as has
counselor jeff lilly and in
when we finally return to the council
chamber
uh i've asked on a number of occasions
that we could have
a better loop system because as it is at
the moment
the only sound we get is the uh
50 cycles per minute bulls
because the microphones are next to the
uh
to the fluorescent lights and that's one
of the background
noises which we could do fairly well and
i suggest uh could the committee ask
them uh
to revamp it or get on with it because
we did ask
at a previous uh well many moons ago to
get you sorted out
but i don't know if it's been done yet
because we haven't been in the council
chamber but
uh it's just a memorandum if it has been
or if it hasn't been
done and if not why not i think it has
been done council armitage because just
before lockdown
workers did come into the chamber to
improve the loop system of course we
won't know if it worked or not because
we haven't returned to be able to do
that
right okay thank you
improve your hearing of the um council
debates but i'm willing to swap places
with you
and not hear council debate sorry
i'll leave it to you
but i think work has been done but of
course we haven't had the opportunity to
uh test that out
so returning to this statement of
accounts um
all of this very relevant um input to
return to the accounts we have got the
recommendations set out to item six
so do we have a mover for those please
thank you council club do you have a
secondary
thank you council armitage all in favor
thank you that is carried um so we move
now to uh corporate
debt go to the uh of you please jane
thank you chair purpose of this report
is to present to members of the audit
covenant scrutiny committee a summary of
the corporate debt position and i've
done it to 31st of august 2020 to make
it as up-to-date as possible
and this is a standard report that you
get on a routine basis however it brings
on a whole new significance as a result
of kobe
as we were just talking about earlier
and it's likely to be a feature i
suspect for many months and certainly
potentially many years to come
during the early months of the pandemic
in line with the government guidance the
council
chose to not take any recovery action
and following the lifting of the
national restrictions and after careful
consideration and consultation with
colleagues across derbyshire
we've now come to the conclusion that
we're going to start a process of
soft recovery what that's about is just
re-engaging with our customers
and trying to open up a dialogue and
offer support rather than
a active chasing of arrears at this
stage we just really need to
start to re-engage six months is an
awful long time to not engage with your
customers so
we haven't started that process yet but
we're going to be starting that in the
next few weeks
and the plan is to carefully monitor the
impact of that
um before we decide what next steps to
take so
if anybody does have any feedback we
would we would welcome that greatly
because this is a
dipping a toe in the water exercise
we're actually
not too bad in terms of debt recovery at
the moment
it's not great but it's not as bad as we
first thought it was going to be um
at the figures are there for you and to
note and i happen to take any questions
yes any comments or questions
council armitage thank you chair uh
how many do we do we know yet how many
uh
businesses have gone to the wall so
we'll never get the money
not at this stage no because we've not
done the recovery action we've yet to
find out other than
people who've actually let us know that
they've they're no longer in business
we wouldn't actually have an accurate
figure on that at this stage
that's one of the reasons why we want to
really start engaging with people just
to find out
who's not there anymore and who's got
difficulties so
so now i can't give you an actual answer
on that at the moment
sorry i got me arrowing wrong please uh
i know i think i'd say i'd support that
what you've just said jane i think it's
uh i think we've got to be careful and
with it that if we
it's a balance between between getting
his money back and
uh and forcing businesses that you know
add to business so
i think like you say a soft recovery is
a way forward but
insane breath we've got to get as money
in help me so it's a delicate one
but i support what you've just said i
think thank you
from my point of view i think it's a
two-edged sword
and of course one of the things we're
talking about is um the council's future
making sure that we're financially
viable and um
where possible collecting money to
support the council's work
but in the same breath we are meant to
be supporting the recovery
of the district um following covid
and we're about to embark on a second
wave i think the statistics
are clear and is this the right time
um that's my question i think
can we not leave it before the soft
recovery
starts until maybe after christmas maybe
start in the spring
2021 rather than just in a few weeks
time
just so that we can see how local
lockdown data comes towards
northeast derbyshire or a second wave
and just give
businesses a little bit more breathing
space
to do is engage with them so so you have
my assurances that before we do anything
heavy-handed we would certainly
we would certainly seek um further
assurances on that
we just want to re-engage because i
think one of the biggest problems that
my revs and ben's team are having at the
moment is
a lack of engagement and if we can just
talk to people
we can start to make arrangements maybe
we've been incredibly flexible
about how long we're letting people pay
for we're even going into future years
we just really need to engage with them
thank you kel shipman
thank you i totally agree with you that
we shouldn't be collecting anything yet
so uh um but um you know the
government's income
uh fund that they've just announced this
week i think
does that cover business rates and stuff
or is that purely for
um our facilities that we've got
you're just cutting in and out counter
shipment on my back yet can you hear me
yeah we can hear you now yeah it was
just it was just you know the
government's income um
fund that they just announced this week
i think it was does that cover
business rates and other incomes like
we're talking about here or is that
purely
back um like does that cover the fund
cover that as well
okay eugene are you referring to the
income compensation scheme is that the
scheme that we're talking about
i think so jane yes i'll be honestly i
don't fully know what it's called
i've just income and some funds about
loss of income i think it's what you're
talking about yeah
yeah the the income compensation scheme
is an absolute god centers i have to be
honest
what where what we're allowed to claim
is and we have to demonstrate that we've
taken all action that we can to mitigate
costs so where we've made savings on
utilities at the leisure centres for
example or where we've been able to
reduce costs through
through using the furlough scheme etc we
do have to take account of that so we're
not getting gross income back
but the government scheme is actually
paying out after the first five percent
of our budget that we set
last year for 2020 after that first five
percent
they're um committing to pay us 75 pence
in the pound
for the income that we're losing so
we've done the first claim today and
that's gone in
um and we're going to have another two
claims so they're doing them every four
months until the end of the year
but that's going to help us massively
because a lot of the leisure income that
we're losing and it's in the region of
1.4 million
we will be able to claim back through
this scheme
so yes i think that's great um
i think it's probably worth as well than
trying to engage with these businesses
and stuff as well because i mean at very
least we might be able to kind of uh
signpost until the grants and stuff that
they've got access to to obviously stop
them going under which is the main thing
because
just before christmas laughing we wanted
people losing jobs and stuff
you want to come back on that please if
i may there is um
i understand because we've not gone into
a local lockdown yet it's not applied to
to derbyshire yet but i do understand
that there are some
further local lock down measures that
are available and in place
specifically addressing that matter so
if we do go into another lockdown i
believe there are some more grants that
we can access
um or that businesses can access buyer
or similar to the business grant scheme
that we did
way back in march um that helped
businesses out a lot i know so
i do believe that there is something but
it's only accessible once you're
designated as another local lockdown
area so
fingers crossed that won't happen in
derbyshire but if it does then there is
something i think it's just
it's not that it's just within our
derbyshire boundaries that sometimes not
neighboring authorities are having
issues
or neighboring um towns cities areas
like sheffield
and really struggling and numbers are
significantly increasing
in terms of coving and what have you and
and some
you know sheffield is somewhere where we
trade um
so i think we have to be mindful of that
sort of thing as well council armitage
yes thank you chad it was just to uh
uh agree with you regarding the uh
getting the debt record uh
if you're going too hard you know you're
going to put them out of business
and i think we've been really looking
towards easter
before we can really start even asking
because we don't know
as jane has said we don't know how many
businesses have already gone to the
world yet
is it the view of the committee then if
we think about the recommendations that
we note the report but also um
that while we agree with the
the soft approach that's been outlined
to the committee
because i think positive conversations
with businesses as well to signpost to
assist
to find ways that they can be helped is
all
very very positive and also to um
to assist them so they don't get into a
position where the debts built up to
such a massive extent that they can't
get out of the hole that they're in
we welcome all of that but we wouldn't
welcome a strong arm approach of
uh bailiffs appearing at the door that
sort of thing this is not a time for
that
and does that sum up how we all feel
that's brilliant thank you i'm getting
the thumbs up from everyone and apart
from councilman who's in darkness
so with that going to recommendation
uh can we have a proposal piece that
6.1 is is moved thank you councillor
second by council
all in favor thank you that is carried
thank you
and then we move to the next item
5c
it's my report
um i think the um this is for those of
you know me who've been
on this committee for previously eight
years
um i was on audit for eight years and i
used to come up with the same mantra
time and time again and one of those is
that the timing of our committee dates
needs to be aligned with
meetings of cabinet there is no point in
my submission
in audit considering reports that have
already gone to cabinet have been
and then been approved there's no
point in us actually looking at
documents that come to us after the fact
when a quarterly report for example is
well and
truly gone and we're considering old
news and officers will know that i used
to say
what is the point of looking at this
it's old news
we need to be a council committee that's
proactive
really scrutinizing information having
our say in influencing the way that
documents are shaped before they go to
cabinet and to full council
therefore one of the things i'm saying
in this report
is that i think we should review the
dates of the committee i know they're
setting the diary but i think
um we should ask the section 151 officer
to come up with a new framework of dates
to make them more realistic and put them
in front of cabinet meeting
times and the other thing we need to be
doing is revising our work plan in light
of
current events and i'm suggesting
implications of covid what a surprise
um that we think about the implications
of brexit or a no brexit deal
and that we do continue with the work
plan in looking at the cost of leisure
services we've just had a figure
banded around this afternoon that is
significant
and of course we have to think about the
um
subsidy of leisure and consider ways of
improving that
and assisting the situation but other
things on the work plan that talk about
some of the things that we have talked
about today so we've talked about
benchmarking we've talked about the
pensions
um there's a whole list of things we've
already agreed that should be part of
our new work plan
so that's what i'm suggesting from
myself and it's over to you for any
comments or questions please
council barker
yeah i fully support that chair i think
that that that makes sense and
uh and and while we accept we're not the
cabinet
but i think we can uh recommend things
to the cabinet and look and and so it i
think the
the the uh the plan is that or it used
to be and i know it gets
changed for for timings and things but
things should come to the audit
committee first
to look at before it then goes to
cabinet and then possibly to council i
think
that's the order it should go out hey up
jerry
jerry's appeared there
but yeah i fully support that and i
think the idea is
it while it's i don't know if it's
classed as a scrutiny committee or not
the audit committee because there's a
there's a there's a thing around that
but
we should be having that input definite
to uh
fully support and and exactly the things
you that you just said the list of
things is
the more that we look at them the more
if that's the better way around that we
look at it first basically i think
you're right
thank you any other comments or
questions
so move the recommendations then so that
uh 6.1 that the audit and corporate
governance
scrutiny committee i just put that in
for council markers benefit
agreed to realign the work plan and
future meeting dates
to meet the objectives detailed in this
report and that we have a revised work
plan to be presented to the next
meeting of the committee that's at 6.2
so i move
those recommendations do you have a sec
linda
thank you council club all in favor
thank you carried so the next item then
um is revised budgets
back over to you please uh section 151
officer
thank you chair i've been doing this job
for a long time and this is probably the
most
challenging budget that i've ever done
with the exception of what we're going
to have to do for the medium term
financial plan so
we normally do this much later in the
year but it felt prudent to me to do it
much earlier because of this
unprecedented
times that we're in with coved so in the
spirit of what we've just discussed this
is the revised budget that report that
will go to cabinet
for on the 8th of october so this is the
opportunity for the scrutiny committee
to give its views and feed those into
cabinet for that meeting
it's the standard report the revised
budget goes through the general fund the
hra
and the capital programme so at appendix
one you'll find the summary for the
general fund for the revised budget
and appendix 2 details the net costs for
each cost centre
as we've discussed at length today the
kobe pandemic is really having an impact
on the
budget it's predominantly fees and
charges and it's predominantly leisure
um but we are losing out on the services
such as mot testing was ground to a
whole for 24 weeks
commercial waste collections we've had a
number of suspensions and cancellations
as a result
and of course we're losing growth on
business rates because whilst
we're not being terribly detrimentally
affected by um
non-collection at this stage we're not
getting the growth either so
all of these things are impacting on the
budget
we have had 1.166 million pounds in
terms of government grant which is
greatly appreciated
i have to say and the income scheme as
we talked about earlier is going to help
us
help us a lot i've put the claim in
today for the first three months and
it's 300
000 pounds so that just gives you an
idea of what we're actually losing
month by month if i can draw your
attention to table 1 below 1.4 in the
revised budget report
what i've what i wanted to demonstrate
in this is that the significance of the
changes that we're talking about this
year
so you'll see from the original report
original budget we were only planning to
move 258 000 pounds from reserves
but we're actually moving 1.9 million
and that's that's
basically to prop up the leisure budgets
the loss of income that we've got
now can i just can i just stop can you
just
so we know where i'm looking at can you
just go back which table are we looking
at sorry
microphone's gone off i can't hear it
can anybody no
sorry i turned it off do apologize
councillor marker
it's page 216.
so if you look at the actual report
attached to the um
revised budget for item 5d
i'm on it right appendix sorry at 1.4
table 1. sorry i've got our on appendix
that's why i couldn't find it
sorry no problem so so you'll see the
second line down that talks about the
revised budget we're taking 1.9 million
from the reserves
this year basically to prop up the
budgets that are being hit hardest
because of coved
and that that sounds rather dramatic but
it's largely funded from the grant which
is largely funded from the money that
we've got from the government so it's
not
it's not quite as bad as it initially
looks like the budget is covered off
and balances by the use of the reserves
this year and the reserves have come
from the government grant so
it's not quite as dramatic as it looks
but it does demonstrate that the
movement from where we were to where we
are now
what table two just below that shows is
how that inc
how those income reductions are broken
down
and then below that it also shows the
efficiency efficiencies that we've
identified in the budget
that offset it by best part of a million
pounds so
the net increase to the revised budget
is 1.3 million pounds
and the table shows how it's how it's
funded
if we do get any surpluses arising this
year and i'm highly skeptical that we
will but if we do get any
surpluses we're going to move those to
the resilience resolver it's proposed
that we remove them to the resilience
reserve to help against future budget
pressures
and i just want to make a point at this
and i know i've labored this point
several times but
the impact of covid on future year
budgets is going to present a real risk
to the mtfp going forward we just don't
know what's going to happen we just
don't know
when we're going to be able to get back
to anything like business as usual
and that's putting a huge pressure on
our income streams and i don't think we
can rely
on government funding beyond this
financial year we may be surprised but i
mean it's a big ask
moving on to the hra the only thing
that's really been affected by the hra
is the level of voids and that's simply
because we haven't been having the
turnaround times that you'd expect
people just haven't been moving as much
and what we do with rents is we we
re-let a
target rent rather than actual rent
which basically just means we move it up
a little bit
now that's negligible to the tenant but
it makes a big difference over seven and
a half thousand properties over the
years so we've just got a bit of a
nudging down in the rents at the moment
nothing significant and as for the
capital programme we did pause the
capital program at the outset because we
just didn't know what the impact was
going to be on cash flow
um and during the lockdown it was very
difficult to do any
any major works anyway but since the
lockdown restrictions have started to be
released we're back up and running and
everybody's working really hard
to recover the time that we've lost
during that period
the appendices show all of the details
so i'm not going to go into any more
detail than that i'm happy to take any
questions
um before we move back to the chair for
the recommendations thank you any
questions council barker
uh yeah just on the appendices that
that's why
i had to look through earlier and and
appendix two i think i'm looking at it
there are some some big changes within
with you know the revised budgets i'm
looking at
uh eh technical support money are there
any of these that that we should be
concerned about basically
question it it's it's difficult to just
to scrutinize on martin no no
that's what we're doing
just before you say ask anymore about
that appendix 2 i i saw some that had
significantly increased increase from
the original budget
yes i mean i picked out um
3401 food health and safety you know
we've gone
forty thousand and three four zero nine
eh support management you just mentioned
nearly fifty
three four two three air quality
feasibility study
yeah 57 000 was suddenly wanting to put
in
394 sorry three
nine four four ground incidents we've
gone up nearly 100 000 pounds
yes that's that later yeah um and
there's lots of others i mean if you go
on the other side
um all those coded fives and so on which
is um
you know a lot of it's to do with um
swimming pools and things
we're going up from one we've got three
hundred thousand extra
yes yes cyber security with
another two hundred thousand and this is
significant figures
if i could tell i'm happy to go through
through those because they're the ones
i've pulled out as well obviously
because i'm obviously as concerned of
them as you
if i can take environmental health as as
a whole
rather than all the individual ones so
the whole of the three four hundreds
range predominantly covers environmental
health
there has been there has been pressures
in environmental health i think it's
been well documented a number of reports
have been taken to
to um various committees about this
recently
my understanding is is that this has
been addressed by the
interim head of service for
environmental health
because they're having difficulties
recruiting they're having to use
agencies which we all know are more
expensive than than
our own staff and it has been a pressure
on the budget and
the best i can offer you at this stage
is that the the head of service
is addressing this matter so i would
hope that it's going to be resolved
it is something that we've actually
flagged in the annual governance
statement as a risk you'll notice so it
is of concern to officers as well
so it's actually been flagged as a risk
in the annual governance statement this
year
so yes that is a that is a concern yeah
i think i think you just you've
talked about one there but five seven
three four
ict service if i could just draw your
attention 200 000.
if i could just draw your attention to
five seven three four five seven three
five and five
seven three six those three together
there's been a restructuring i t
and that's resulted in a change of cost
centers if you take the three together
it's actually a 45 000 pound loss and if
i could just while we're on the subject
mentioned the air quality feasibility
study you're absolutely right that is 57
000
but that's holy grant funded and that
does happen through some of these
what happens above the line is the costs
come in and then below the line
i move it out if it's a grant funded
scheme and the air quality feasibility
is one of those sort of schemes
so does that explain eight four four one
effington swimming pool we're suddenly
forking out another three hundred
thousand that's the loss of income from
the
loss of income yep from the leisure
centres being closed because of covert
yeah drum field center similar all three
part
similar yeah devastating it is awful
do we not care about business
development anymore five seven
three six nearly we've reduced it by uh
nearly a quarter of a million don't we
care about business five seven three
four five seven three five and five
seven three six are all ict the three
together
uh come back to a total budget of 466
thousand pound it's just a recoding
issue
chair right i think that will need to be
made clear to
the council when they look at this
because on the face of it
when you look at appendix 2 um the stark
reality of some of this
is quite breathtaking um and i think
when you explain that some of it is
about coding issues and some of them are
bracketed together and the explanations
you've given which are
you know clarify those sorts of things
and would help
members of council looking at a budget
of this description
as i say some of it is still so shocking
um and there are still some things i
think some heads of service and some
portfolio holders will will need to
explain why this sudden
increases we've just i've just pulled
out some examples just like council
marketed there are others
council market
thank you chair yeah i suppose going
back to where i started it
exactly what you said and i expected
that that because i've
made myself looked after at times and
said well why's that and they've just
moved it to somewhere else
so that happens but i think a bit of a
narrative report like you've done with
the
the main budget would explain away some
of those
there are i mean just to say because you
know that's the loss of income
i mean that that is you know what it
doesn't naturally say that that's loss
of income it mean it looks like we spent
more
rather than lost the income so just a
narrative
alongside that would explain it it don't
it don't take away that how much it
disgusted
i don't think it is but what the other
examples that that
council thackers just highlighted that
this
it you know can we afford to keep just
be spending more on some things
when we've got save all that money
exposes the question
yes councilor barker the intention i
absolutely take on board what you're
saying the intention of table two
is to provide that overview of all of
the key variances within the report but
i do accept that that is very high level
and it is unusual this year because it's
predominantly loaded with income losses
because of the covered situation but
more than happy to put more narrative
into the report you know
i myself go through every single line
and there were every single variances
because
because i need to know so more than
happy to provide more information if
that's
if that's what the committee would like
thank you so it doesn't take away from
the fact there are some concerns in that
appendix too and you've highlighted
quite rightly the one about ground
maintenance
which i'm pleased that you're aware of
and share concerns as well
um there are as i say one two others
like that where you think well
somebody's got to explain how we got to
that revised figure
i i thought at one point and this
certainly was talked about
at the viper meetings that we have them
that we had a moratorium on an
expenditure
and we had a moratorium on things like
recruitment
um and i think we still ought to be
mindful of those sorts of things as we
are still in covid
we have not left kobe we're not in a
post coping situation
and and i'm not aware of anywhere where
there's been an update on
on the moratorium and how that's
actually helped to
support the council and where we're at
if i may chair that was taken to cabinet
as the quarterly budget monitoring
report
so i have been updating cabinet the
cabinet nobody
well hopefully with the new timetable
you will know first
okay see i rest my kids your case is
made well
are there any other comments or
questions on that
my only other one is to do with ricknall
1.7 in the report main report itself on
page 2017 we've talked about
um rick nolan goes over the page about
the 20 21 22 fee
do we have any ideas what will be
happening with that fee and where are we
with ricknald
the short answer is no we haven't set
the fee yet we'll do that as part of the
median term financial plan so i will be
doing it in the next
couple of months um so
the short answer is no i haven't got a
viewers yet
i'm sure that could be something that
comes to our next meeting for us to have
a
comment about and discuss rick north and
so on council shipment
just just on written chair um given the
fact that we give them nine point
well best part of 10 million quid uh
wouldn't it be proven if we saw what
their budget looked like and whether
theirs
is going up and down in certain places
so we can actually scrutinize
that expenditure because to me um
that's a large portion of any ddc's
budget and it's you know if people ask
us well what's it spent on i mean i
don't know about you but i'll just go
it's on hours
i won't be able to tell you whether it's
the management of the houses whether
it's
the voids whether it's getting people
into homes or what
and i think that we should actually get
this information in front of us as
possible if possible
is that a recommendation council
shipping that it's added to our work
plan
it is that's brilliant so we can add it
to our work class
did you want to respond to that saddafi
or are you going to let councilman come
in
yeah just just on that really i mean
with me x reign or that on is that rick
not have got
well i know it's all changing or
changing in both sets of changing with
the
with the boards and things but rick will
get that money
and they've got uh like a finance sub
board if you like that then looks at all
the
that they look at what happens with that
money
and it's all i think it's all on the
wrignuel website and say
we can see it but i think
uh i don't know now again jane i'm
looking for advice with the changes how
much influence
we we allocate them the money and
written all the
when it was an elmo i don't know i don't
think it is anymore but when it was an
elmo they basically got that money
and could do what they are you know it
were up to the board to decide what
happened with that money
the council just decided how much they
got so
i'm not quite sure with the new
arrangement how much influence we've
we can still look at it and see because
i think that that's been a question
from from our group well where's that
money being spent
uh it you have to it is on the uh
written all sorts of websites and things
you can
find it but it's a lot easier if
somebody's telling you're into it so
just a bit of guidance jane really how
much influence we've got in all that
in response to your comments council
barca i mean i think you're mixing davey
crockett
crockett up with the alamos and elmo's
um but did i say out did i say alamo
you'd say brilliant
[Laughter]
but um so we're not thinking about david
crockett
um in terms of the the fact it's
it is public money from this council
that's used
and nobody's disputing about the way
it's used um
and i'm sure it's been used in the best
way possible but we still have a
responsibility to scrutinize
um what rick miller is doing with that
public money and it's not just about the
management fee
it's about um the the whole setup of
ricknoll and
i think it's a welcome opportunity for
uh representatives of richmond to come
along and talk to us you know we are
meant to
scrutinize them um and i would expect
that they
expect to be scrutinized i'm sure the
chief executive would expect to be
scrutinized i'm sure she wouldn't mind
coming along in fact it would be an
opportunity for her to
share with us how proud she is of the
organization and talk to us about all
sorts of things and we can ask those
questions we want to ask
and i think that sums it up to me
so that's the wrinkle
anything else on the report if not can
we move to recommendations at paragraph
six do we have a proposal please for
those
thank you council armitage do you have a
second it thank you council shipment all
in favor
thank you that is carried
so we now move to uh
item six uh we don't have the monitoring
officer here
so the annual governance statement is
that over to you
i will take that one chair in the
monitoring offices
and i'm not an expert on the annual
governance statement so please bear with
me on this one and i'm pretty much just
going to paraphrase the report but
as you'll all be aware the as part of
the statement of accounts the council is
required to make an annual governance
statement
and preparation of the statements need
to be in line with the
society of local chief executives and
senior managers solas for short
and there's a framework for that so
basically there's a framework that
identifies that local authorities should
be behaving with integrity
openness showing demonstrating
sustainable economic social and
environmental benefits
and there's a whole list of things that
we should be checking against
and part of the reason that we do the
annual governance statement is to
provide that annual assessment process
to do that so you'll find a copy of the
annual governance statement
appendix one it has been reviewed this
year and
shortened to hopefully make it slightly
more readable i know it's been quite
unwieldy in the past so
um we'd be happy to take your feedback
on that and
as to whether it is a little bit more
accessible and readable
um we then also do a review of the code
of corporate governance which is at
appendix 2
and that's measured in line with the sit
for solace basics again
and we do a benchmarking exercise which
is appendix 3.
i appreciate there's an awful lot of
information in appendix 2 in appendix 3
to 2 wheeled through but
but sarah and myself have been through
that in detail and done the
self-assessment
and then at appendix 4 there's a draft
memo from this committee
that the chief financial officer the
monitoring officer
to the leader of the council um and head
of paid service which recommends that
the annual governance statement gives a
true and very view of the council's
position within the authority
um and it's for those to sign off so
there's a recommendation at the end of
this report that you give authority to
the chair of this committee to sign the
annual governance statement on your
behalf this year
thank you and i'm happy to take any
questions any comments or questions
just a couple from me um
first of all on the um role
of the audit committee which is on page
241 of the bundle
um in the box there the very first
bullet point
agreeing the annual governance statement
and the annual statement of accounts
it makes it sound like we're a rubber
stamp in exercise
and i don't believe we are i think the
that's probably not
the right wording for it um
so i think that there needs to be a
change of vocabulary there
and rather than agreeing i think we're a
bit more than that
um it could be scrutinizing the annual
governance statement and the annual
statement of accounts probably um
and and then approving rather than
making it sound like really
just as i say rubber stamping exercise
and i do believe it should be another
bullet point because there's only four
um
because another role that we take is one
of our main functions is um
looking at the accountability of the
council's income and expenditure
decision making processes and their
impact
on the district
um that's my other bullet point
and my other comment relates to um
appendix one
page 245 of the bundle on the
coronavirus pandemic the council's
response
um i i actually think we've undersold
ourselves
there's not enough information about the
council's response
the impact on our services it just we
haven't talked about all the other
things that this council has done
in terms of impact of our services and
particularly the support in our
community
all the things that we covered during
our viper meetings
all the things that we did to actually
support the
community during that time i'm sure
there'll be minutes of our vira
viper meetings that can provide evidence
of some of the things that we did
um could be added to make that
a more robust explanation of
the council's response um
again the plans for recovery seem a bit
feeble i think we did a lot more than
that
we also made some decisions relating to
um
moratorium on expenditure recruitment
and so on
as a result of covid so i think they
ought to be reflected in there
council market
yeah i think you're right i must admit
i'd not read it word for word this bit
so
i have missed that bit page i apologize
but
yeah fully support and i think the the
thing we did with the uh
twin oaks and the homelessness and then
because i know uh
i think you had an uh a part to play in
that you know
coordinating all that so i think i think
we were leading it as a northeast
weren't we
in some way in setting that up uh
no i think you're right i think if we
can
sort of put in a lot more as how
this well i think and again i'm i'm
uh i'm praising you martin but i think
we led on a lot of things
northeast arms you we were the first to
instigate quite a lot of the uh
the things you know uh the the others
followed if you like and i think we
should
definitely be that talk and yeah and
regarding your your bullet point thing i
think you
you're right i i mean i don't know how
generic these
these uh statements are you know they
just
copy and paste from another one and just
changed name i don't know but
that that's definitely uh something we
could add that bullet point for me
thank you i think we did lead and i will
say that
as a district council we were doing a
lot more than others
across the whole of the county and it
doesn't feel like it's reflected in the
in the statement i've seen in reports
elsewhere i think
people refer to all the work we're doing
there's lots of
cross-referencing i think if we're going
to do a statement that summarizes
those three areas i think we can do
better than that
any other comments or questions anything
from the section 151 officer in response
to
to all of that no we can make those
changes chair that's absolutely fine the
recommendation at 6.1
asks for the committee's observation
observations and recommendations
prior to the final version being
incorporated so we'll add those in and
then you i believe 6.3 then gives you
the authority to sign it off without it
coming back to committee thank you and
council shipment
um it's just a concern about what's
written as a mitigation for the failure
to adopt the local plan
in the report it says um obviously one
of the issues is
a local
yeah 242 bottom right box
of the uh table it just says the council
is an advanced stage in preparation
for that tells me current where we
currently are it doesn't say what we're
actually doing to
hurry that along um when we expect it to
be adopted
uh which is that i'm sure the date that
myself and many other committee members
would like to hear when it's expected
uh you know even a rough day you know is
it 20 21 is it 2022 is it you know
when we're on it for election again when
is it when does it do
because i don't feel we're getting any
information about this and i know it's
an issue
which resonates with a lot of people in
many
areas across northeast derbyshire um so
it'd be nice to know
if we can actually get a firm mitigation
of the failures to adopt local plan
rather than
just telling us where we are at the
moment yeah i think
if you go on to page 243 at the top
it then carries on with a bit more
information
um about what the council has done but
i think the the sentence there that
we're at an advanced
stage in preparation of the local planet
i don't think any of us would know that
it is
um and probably from my point of view as
the chair of this committee i would
probably strike that sentence out
um i would strike the sentence out and
then leave it that the council has
taken steps in the preparation of the
plan
uh with requirements i know there's been
legal
um comments and so on um and taking
advice
and that there's been consultation
undertaken during 2019-20
i'll probably take out the word
considerable
um i i'd like to know what what these
steps are that have been taken and what
actually the advice is because i think
that is the mitigation in
what should be in this report it's all
women good you know we
we're doing something well this
committee needs to know
what it is we're doing to mitigate that
risk
no fair comment does anybody else want
to add to that
does anybody know anything different
or do we feel that that box ought to be
revised to um
explain that there has been a pause in
the local plan
and that the plan has um
has been restarted but i think we don't
know much more than that really at this
stage
is that a fair reflection
yeah i think
situation with the plan is that uh it
was paused
uh it then went to the examiner
who then uh sent it back with some
recommendations
uh which were done and then it's been
sent back to them
again uh and i think
i would hope that it's going to be
all done adjusted by christmas but uh
i understand that the uh the examiner uh
was on holiday uh recently so
uh allowing for holidays uh it could it
could or should be done i would hope by
christmas
yeah i think what we're dealing though
is conjecture here
and you know we hope or we might think
or whatever
do we know and all we know is that the
plan's been paused
it's been reason for um further comments
to be sent to the examiner
and i think that's where we're at
i don't i don't think we can say more
than that
it's with the examiner at the moment
well then
we know it's at so i think if we could
just revise the statement to um
be one that's probably a bit more
realistic for this committee to support
um are we all happy with that
yeah thank you right that's lovely thank
you so thank you
for that um it will come back
to myself for um final comment so i will
look at that one specifically
and and then we'll look at the others
we've just talked about
so um with all of that in mind we move
to the recommendations from 6.1 to 6.3
inclusive
so can we have a mover for those please
thank you council club
second to please
thank you councillor rowe all in favor
that's carried thank you and the next
one is reports of the internal audit
consortium so am i handing over to jenny
don't you then please
thank you um yes so the first report is
our annual report for 1920
and this summarizes the work we've
undertaken in 1920 compared to the
original plan
and so the content of the report is was
what's advised by the public sector
internal audit standards
um so in spite of kobit 19 we did
complete the majority
of the 2019-20 plan and that means that
i can give
an opinion on the council's internal
control environment
and the table on page two
shows that we issued 24 reports in
2019-20
and you'll be very pleased to know that
all of those reports were in our top two
categories of assurance which are
substantial and reasonable
and we see both of those as being
positive assurances
and so all of the reports have been
included on progress reports
to the committee during the year the
last of which is is later on the agenda
today
um appendix a that shows you
that details all of those 24 reports for
you
and the exact opinion for those areas
and the opinion the previous time that
we looked at them
you'll be pleased to know that we didn't
identify any fraud issues during the
year
uh the table on page three that looks
are key performance indicators
um we've completed 86 of the plan
against the target of 96
and i say that was due partially to
covid hitting in the middle of march
we did lose two auditors during the year
uh
and we also have two sit for
apprenticeships and there's quite a time
commitment
involved in training those staff
and so for 2021 i've reset the target at
75 percent and for the 2021 plan and
we'll keep that under constant
review and revision and the rest of the
indicators were all positive
um it's really pleasing to see customer
satisfaction rates
up at 94 percent at paragraphs 1.8 to
1.11
they detail the overall conclusion on
the council's control environment
so in my opinion as audit manager
we can give reasonable assurance as 100
of areas
did receive those substantial or
reasonable assurance opinions the
internal
control issues were considered in terms
of the annual governance statement and
if anything needed to be included
and we did determine that we didn't
think there was anything
of such significance from our work that
needed to
be reflected in the annual government
statement
so paragraph 1.15 that details the
comparison of planned work
against completed so we didn't complete
four reviews
and one of those elections was brought
into 2021 and we have now just issued
that report
um two other areas ir 35 and the use of
consultants we've carried those forward
into 2021
um we didn't undertake the main
accounting budget control audit
um and we're not we're not going to do
that for 1920 now because we have to
undertaken
um a comprehensive review against the
sit for financial management code
and so moving on to compliance with the
public sector audit standards
in may i undertook a self-assessment
um against the standards and in my
opinion we are meeting the standards
um in october 16 we had an external
review
which did agree that we're compliant
with the standards there's a gender item
later on about the external review
because we do have to have one every
five years
and so that is due again next summer
uh we do have quality control procedures
in place and i make sure that all my
staff
are aware of the standards that they
should be adhering to
i can confirm that we are independent i
do have
direct access to the strategic clients
management team if i need it
and again to yourselves
i do think
agenda today for you to approve
so the recommendation is the internal
audit consortium annual report
for 1920 be noted and
i'll try and answer any questions
thank you any comments or questions from
the committee
all in favor thank you that's carried
so we're moving on to the review of the
internal audit charter so back to you
which you've already alluded to
thank you chair yeah so this is a review
of our charter which which they used to
call it the
terms of reference but it's called the
charter now
um this committee last um approved this
uh two years ago in june 2018
um and the public sector standards do
require that we have this charter to
define
our purpose authority and responsibility
and there haven't been any changes to
the public sector internal audit
standards since i wrote the charter
um and so i'm reviewing the charter i do
think it's still
fit for purpose i've just updated um a
few of the job titles in there
so for our recommending now that we do
bring the charter every year
instead of every two years so i will be
bringing it every year from now on but
the recommendation is that members note
and agree the outcome of the review of
the charter
yeah thank you i'm assuming that the
change of titles were on page
301 of the bundle 38
sorry i've got different page numbers to
yourself but it's basically um
the chief exec title changing to
corporate results direct to corporate
resources that's what i'm referring to
any comments or questions
council barker
just a comment really because for me
since i'm also on audit committee at the
county council and uh
they they're having same same issues you
know we covered in one thing or another
but
they've also had issues recruiting
people and i think you'll
you just said something there that
you've lost two members of staff
your year and it seems to be basically i
know what the county council
they can't get these people to do
internal audits are we
are we are right at our end at this end
at the moment we're fully staffed um
and we did manage to recruit um
unfortunately a couple of years ago a
very experienced senior internal auditor
but i think we were
we're quite lucky to get him because
i've seen the county council adverts
and the difficulties in recruiting um
we have recruited an internal auditor
who's
got different experience here we are
going to have to actually train him up
because he hasn't got
in much internal audit experience and
but we've looked at other
qualities that that we wanted and and
we're happy that
he had those and that we would be able
to train him but we are fully staffed at
the moment thankfully because there is a
shortage of
um professional internal auditors out
there
thank you so any other comments or
questions
don't remove the recommendations at six
at six point one to six point three
inclusive do we have a proposal please
thank you council club second uh
council armitage thank you all in favor
thank you that's carried
so next one external review of internal
internal audit
thank you yes this is just to advise you
really that our external
uh review is due the public sector
internal audit standards do require
that we have an external review um every
five years
and that's really so you're not just
relying on taking my word for it that we
are doing what we're supposed to do
so the external reviewer comes in to
give you the assurance hopefully
that we are performing in line with best
practice and adhering to the standards
um so as i said we had our last review
in july 16 and the full
results were reported to this committee
in the october
um so they do require that i just
consult with members
um about the proposal um
so the main aspect of the review will be
to
complete the public sector internal
audit standards checklist
and that should tell us if there's any
areas where we need to improve
and if we get an experienced reviewer
hopefully they'll be able to pass us on
some uh
ideal ways that other councils are
operating as well
so i'm proposing to go out and get some
quotes from beautifully
qualified parties um i do think that's a
better option
than doing a peer review they haven't
taken off in the midlands
i think it's the fear that they'll
potentially sour relations with other
councils
um i did survey the midlands audit group
to try and find out
who they'd use to establish who to ask
to quote
it's a very small number actually one
person had used the institute of
internal auditors
aided used robin pritchard um from
gateway shore and
he actually conducted our last internal
review
uh an eight had used it for or the two
sit for representatives in their
private companies and so those
two parties are both really experienced
and people that i would certainly start
with asking to quote
so i'm asking that the committee
delegate authority to myself from the
section 151 officers
to set a specification for the review so
in that specification would be ask them
to completing the checklist and they do
that by
looking at our working processes looking
at our documentation
uh speaking to officers probably
speaking to the chairs of the audit
committee
so they could form an opinion on how we
work
uh happy to answer any questions on that
my question was about the budget set the
ten thousand
is that um that is
because that could be more than we need
based on last time was three thousand
six hundred
um i'm hoping it won't come in at that
much again it depends there's quite a
big
price discrepancy if you if you use sit
for
certainly last time when we went to
tender they were um
a lot more expensive than the company
that we used in the end
so it's getting a balance between cost
and quality
um which would which we'd certainly use
in the specification and
when assessing the quotes and we would
get a balance between cost and quality
and so given the price last time i would
hope it would come under
that's a that's a cautious estimate but
again i'm not sure
how much they will have gone up in in
five years
what would happen if it's not a cautious
estimate
would you need to come back before this
committee
um at it fortunately
it split four ways because so for each
council
hopefully it wouldn't be an extortionist
amount
more because the cost is split between
darsh dales north east bolsover and
chesterfield
but if it was dramatically different i
guess we would have to
um consult with the accountants and come
back to the committee to say that
we needed more money but it is something
that we
do have to do to comply with best
practices have this review
let's hope it's not forty thousand then
split four ways
that's all questions
if not then can we move the
recommendations to section c
6.1 6.2 do we have a proposal thank you
council shipment do you have a second uh
council armitage you're all in favor
that's carried thank you and then the
next one progress update on the 2019
20 20 20 21 internal audit plans
thank you that's my last one um yeah so
this
uh report hopefully summarizes for you
and the work we've been doing
um as mentioned earlier we have
substantially completed the 1920 plan
uh we were late completing that plan i
say due to the reasons already given
partly covered
partly staff shortages and training
commitments
and that will have a bit of a knock-on
effect on our ability to complete the
2021 plans
and if if we go into lockdown again that
will also make things
harder for us um as we
were in recovery we were finding it
easier to progress audits
um i guess the future is a bit unknown
but we will try our best to continue
as we can um if you turn to appendix 2
this period we've issued 13 reports
eight with substantial assurance and
five with reasonable assurance so
that's really an excellent set of
results and there's no particular issues
in relation to those audits
that i feel i need to bring to your
attention
again we haven't identified any fraud
issues
that you need to be aware of um
appendix 3 that's a new appendix to just
try and give you an idea of
how we're progressing on the 2021 plan
um so at the time of the writing this
report we'd issued four reports
since then we have also issued
procurement and elections
the results are branch i'll bring next
time
um we're also very close to issuing the
asset management report
so at this time last year we had issued
slightly more reports than that but
we're not drastically behind um in
october i'll be
taking out a mid-year review of the plan
and talking to the section 151 offices
to see if there's any
um higher risk areas that we perhaps
need to supplement our plan with
and we'll keep working on the plan um as
best we can
so the recommendations is that the
report be noted
uh and that there is an impact of
coronavirus on our ability to complete
the whole of the
current year plan um but i'm hopeful at
the moment that
we will achieve enough of the plan to be
for me to be able to provide
an audit opinion for 2021
and try and answer any questions let's
try to find appendix 3
one of the new things that's been added
is ethics
so what sort of um issues are you going
to be covering in ethics or is the only
way ethics
um it's not an audit we've done before
it's a new audit for us
and we have done it in different
elements before but it's pulling things
together
so it's it is looking at governance
arrangements transparency things like
um look at offices expenses
um uh recruitment and selection
uh making sure we've got things in place
for in terms of governance
it's quite wide ranging and getting
overall
all view on you know is there a code of
conduct is that regularly reviewed and
there's a whole raft of things we'd look
at within that area
and the layer of acetate that you're
putting across all of these will
will be covered of course and the impact
of covid
yes on all the audits we're doing we'll
have to consider if if
the impact of covet has affected the
controls in place at all
uh and what the impact of that has been
are there any other comments or
questions from the committee
now so most recommendation then to
section six
um 6.2 we just mentioned that so that's
particularly relevant about the impact
of
coronavirus on all of this this work so
do we have a proposal for those
recommendations council club thank you
do you have a second
council shipment just made it and all in
favor
thank you that's carried thank you for
that um
so item eight there are no other items
that are considered as a match of
urgency
so can i thank you for your attendance
and declare the meeting
closed thank you
you